[Music]
oh
what today's challenge is a racket
building battle we have to invent a
completely new Tilton racket 100 budget
2 hours time time
now let's hunt the the required objects
first thing a figure saw let's figure
out which figure saw we're going to take
maybe I'll take this one for my recet
I'm thinking about some extra reach this
isn't what I'm looking for CU this the
only Opera they have in Finland next
door no luck my raet involves a
revolutionary technology perhaps it's in
the sports section I have found my blade
I hope they don't mind that I'm opening
up the bag we'll have to modify the
extensions we'll need a different shop
for that Emil is also shopping here I'm
going to have to hide from him maybe spy
on him see what he's up to then we need
a veneer sheet which one has the best
sound this is the thing that I I need
but I don't need this big or do I need
how big do we want to make the rocket is
the question it only makes sense to make
a big rocket for a big guy this is what
we're looking
for ah a nice looking handle look at
that it's not a bad idea actually like
here would be a raet head and then you
smash it's going to have to be like a
flat surface that's going to be like I'd
like cut a shape like that maybe the
second extension could be this direction
then you could play both ways we need a
chain next something like this has to be
strong could that work that could work
it's going to be very cool I promise you
who is that guy what is he doing he's
spying on me get away typical cheater I
think the sausage racket that's in the
back now but from the umbrella how would
I do
that should I maybe use this bit in
between
maybe I could have three extensions
it'll be like a super wide extension
it'll have to be perfect fit instruction
manual won't be needing that I'll I'll
spend ages building this and have no
idea how it actually works until we're
back at the
hall welcome to Emil's corner so the
first thing I'm going to take vineer
take the measures of of a real racket
just to get the the right size I will
need a bit longer this part we just need
to start cutting it I expected it to be
faster and I'm done
myself and now this is so much
better yeah the first piece is off
making the first attachment this is
going to take a
while I I've done half a centimeter look
this might actually
work maybe I could have used scissors to
cut this whole thing next how do we
attach this I'll try super blue I'm
going to put like rubber bands these
rubber bands are so old they shouldn't
break like
this I don't have
time sa stick let's get on with
[Music]
it something like that next
thing so basically this is going to be
my racket there one
[Music]
I don't even need to get this really
tight it's done I'm sure I'm going to
win every challenge with this I'm
happy that was a bit faster work smarter
not
harder it's starting to look like a
racket like slowly but
steadily how suspicious does this look
final push come on this is the base of
the racket this is going to be handle
one block to each side and then let's
cut this
one I don't think many people cut their
Handles in two parts then we need the
drill it's creating a fire true number
one does it fit dust then we put the
chain there it's going to be so good
like I'm so excited about this already
now I'm doing my racket's secret second
extension and it needs to fit between
the claw our third and final
extension yes no now I need to do is
glue it there all they need are the
rubbers and a slight aesthetic
modification and since we're closing in
on the time limit I better get cracking
so the building process has been done
who will go first I think you can start
em okay I'll take the honor to be first
just wait and see for this one okay guys
oh what surprise before we show our
rackets we want to tell you about our
holiday campaign our online store is now
full of amazing offers and when you
order anything over 50 you'll get a
unique greeting card signed by all three
of us the card also includes a QR code
that opens an exclusive bonus video just
for you so treat yourself or surprise
your loved ones by heading over to P
infinity.
store but now let's get back to my
record oh what nunchuck I like the
craftsmanship emal you've done a good
job do you think that's going to bring
some good power to the shots I hope
so this will be extremely hard to play
with it's more like a
weapon I think you could play with this
in the tournament maybe not the best
idea somebody who knows the ITF
regulations about blades let us know
would this pass an International
Tournament I can go next Emil brought
out the nunchucks what's up they going
to bring out it's the EM Chuck the name
of of the of the rackets okay you can
open it's a what no no no no it's
basically a normal table than rets
there's there's a catch to this yes I'm
not the fastest mover I have a good
reach but you can always use some
extra oh oh that's cool if I do forand
here the whole table's open not
anymore not anymore I was worried that's
going to happen but at least it lasted
for a while that's the coolest thing
that I've ever seen I would definitely
buy this there some developing still to
be done lastly M I think the standard is
pretty high now behold the vibrator to
make extreme power in the shot okay Em's
not
impressed and he's broken it I will
never give you anything ever okay I want
to your luckily it comes with spare
what that broke
too I I hope there is a spare part do
the spare part well actually there is
the last spare part the Vibra
wall yeah good good try make good try
I'll have to reinforce this with some
tape next are the challenges let's see
which rocket takes the win and the first
one is to bounce the ball 10 times on
your record go 3 4 5 6 7 that that's it
that's it your record was made for that
it was okay now you have to do it with
the extension isn't that much harder
with the
extension this is obviously going to be
a bit hard but this is the thing that's
cheating if I needed to use the
extension you need to use record ly we
need harder challenges for the next one
there's going to be a high bounce and
then you have to smash it this is might
be the one where it breaks
okay it was just
slower ni oh it holds up theu let's hope
it won't come off me
too
oh it's it's insane next challenge is
who imitates the
robot next challenge who can create spin
on their shots let's do it
oh wow uhh can I do this without the
extension
yes
oh I'm very curious to see the Amil
Chuck come on Amil
Norris the deciding challenge will be up
to you guys once again we'll put an
Instagram poll asking whose racket will
you guys choose get an Expendable racket
the most dangerous ping pong racket in
the world vibratron 2000 the results are
in the third place with 21% of votes the
vibrating
racket it's still bronze and the winner
of the racket battle with over 50% of
the
vote extension
ret let us know in the comments below
which racket building battle we should
do next time if you don't want to buy
one of our silly rackets we have proper
rackets of pongf do store go and check
it out pongf do store